- I'm Chris Cotton
and I'm here at the
roast to Bruce Willis
with the one and
only Flula Borg.
- What did you say? Who?
- Flula Borg.
- No, no.
My name's Gruber.
- (Chris) Some might say
your arch nemisis is here.
What is your plans at the roast?
- I plan to look
John in the face
and say, "John, I'm
not dead big boy,
I'm here.
"I'm ready.
"Let's blow some **** up."
- At the end of
the movie, you die
because you fell off the roof,
but you're here tonight,
so how exactly did you
make it after that?
- Did you not see
the swimming pool?
- There was a
swimming pool, but-
- I'm an Olympian swimmer.
Have you met Mark Spitz,
seven time gold medal winner?
- Well, according to ...
- I am Mark Spitz.
- I don't know if you can tell,
but you're making me very hot.
- I noticed you're
perspiring very deeply.
- Do you think it will be
better to rob an art museum,
or a jewelry store?
- It depends on how much
jewelry is in the jewelry store.
If it's under 50 thousand
Euros, I won't touch it.
- What about in pounds?
What if the money was in pounds?
- Oh I'll do pounds.
I'll do pounds.
- Okay, you'll do pounds.
- Yeah, I'm into crypto.
I'm getting very
deep into crypto,
- So did you invest in Bitcoin?
- I've created my
own coin, Grube coin.
- So, I would like some Grubes.
Can we talk about
investing in Grubes later.
- Yes.
I will give you my
exchange rate off the air.
- Thank you sir.
Would you change anything
about how you
executed your plan?
- Yes, I would have held
onto Holly Gennero's wrist,
not her wrist watch.
- We all thought the same th-
- Gravity is, as
they say, a *****.